If you want to see how Twinkies are hidden
in several shots throughout the movie, then
stick around to the end of this video.
[INTRO]
Ahh 2009.
It was the end of the decade, Nigahiga was
the biggest YouTuber with less than 2 million
subscribers, "I'm gonna be telling you guys
all the great wonderful reasons 2009 sucked platypus sh--"
and a comedy-horror called Zombieland became
the darling of pop-culture in an October noticeably
void of many horror movies.
Sounds familiar?
*Crickets*
Let's get into the Things You Missed.
[Things You Missed]
The film opens up by showing zombies at the US capitol building in Washington DC, something that
looks like it may be revisited in the sequel,
and after a zoom out you can see some of the
rides at Pacific Playland, which the characters
would visit at the end of the movie.
As Columbus is going over the rules, he mentions
an interesting observation.
"When you’re at your most vulnerable, somehow
they could just smell it."
This could explain why so many of them gather
at the end of the movie, outside of the fact
that Wichita and Little Rock already drawing
extra attention to themselves by turning on
the theme park.
The opening credits are animated to react
to each of the scenes, and the director's
credit, Ruben Fleischer, gets jumbled around
so that it reads Ruben Flesh.
You know, cause zombies eat flesh.
Tallahassee paints the number 3 on both of
his cars.
This is probably a tribute to American racecar
driver Dale Earnhardt Jr, who also uses the
number 3 and can be seen on a poster in Tallahassee's
flashback.
Columbus never makes it back to Ohio to see
if his parents are still alive, but he does
mention that they are also paranoid shut ins much
like himself.
Maybe there's a hint that they are still
alive for the sequel.
During his flashback, I noticed a very nice
piece of Aqua Teen Hunger Force Art on the
wall.
It's probably a sign of things to come because
hunger is the main factor that drives not
only the zombies but also Tallahassee.
"WHERE ARE YA YOU SPONGY YELLOW DELICIOUS BASTARDS, WHERE ARE YA?"
Columbus
also drinks can after can of Mountain Dew:
Code Red.
Code Red is usually a term used to describe
a state of emergency, which would be an accurate
way to label the zombie outbreak seen in the
movie.
Columbus and his hot neighbor call each other
by their apartment numbers, which keeps up
the trend of there being no real names used
for most of this movie.
When she turns into a zombie and comes after
him into the bathroom, the subtle joke is
that he sprays her with disinfectant spray,
zombies are often also called "the infected",
so it's kind of funny to think that something
like that would work.
The Twinkie search takes Columbus and Tallahassee
to Blaine’s Grocery, a name that was later
used in a 2013 zombie survival game called
State of Decay.
Wichita and Little Rock's scheme is to make
the boys think that Little Rock is infected
in order for Wichita to do the honors on her
sister, only to steal the guns and the vehicle.
That’s a pretty risky plan if you ask me,
how did they know Tallahassee wouldn’t just
fire without hesitation right about here?
Tallahassee's longing for a Twinkie continues
after the guys lose all their stuff.
“Believe it or not, Twinkies have an expiration
date.”
This is a reference a well-traveled myth that
Twinkies never expire, but in reality they
last about 25 days.
If Tallahassee is aware of this fact, that
means almost all of North America was wiped
out under one month ago.
“It’s amazing how quickly things can go
from bad to total s***storm.”
When Columbus and Tallahassee make it to the
next town, a couple of upside-down American
flags can be seen.
This could be somewhat of a new flag for Zombieland,
because we also see an inverted star spangled
banner in the opening shot of the movie.
There’s also some humorous stuff hidden
in the background of the town scene, like
a bridal shop plastered with anti-zombie propaganda,
and one store with a no zombies sign, as if
saying that they weren’t allowed in would
somehow protect them.
Maybe the owners of that store mixed up zombies
with vampires.
I’ll come back to analyse the car scene
later in this video, but I’ve just got to
point out… they waste a LOT of ammo in this
movie.
In the scene that shows one of Wichita and
Little Rock’s pre-Zombieland scams, this
gas station employee is the same guy from
the beware of bathrooms example seen two minutes
into the movie.
Poor dude just can’t catch a break.
There’s also a gag that appears a couple
times where the characters reference something
called “zombie kill of the week.”
“Very cool.
But… zombie kill of the week?
Hmmm no sir.”
It comes up again later when they get to the
Indian trading post.
Zombie kill of the week?”
“Close, but no cigar.
Zombie kill of the week goes to sister Cynthia
Knickerbocker.”
I don’t know how Columbus would have known
about this.
I’m pretty sure there’s no TV or internet
at this point.
Apparently the idea for ‘Zombie Kill of
the Week’ is actually left over from when
the script for Zombieland was actually being
considered as a weekly TV show rather than
a movie.
But let’s say they do know about Cynthia
Knickerbocker.
That would help explain this line later on
from Tallahassee.
“Six people left in the world and one of
them’s Bill ****ing Murray.”
So, Columbus, Tallahassee, Bill Murray, Wichita,
Little Rock and Cynthia Knickerbocker are
the six people left, as far as we know.
Their next stop is at this Native American
gift shop place a location stuffed with even
more hidden meanings and Things You Missed.
At the trading post, OK I wouldn’t normally
point out something this random, but this
hat is the same hat that Jessie wears in Toy
Story 2, I mean it’s the EXACT hat, that’s
the only reason I bring it up.
And this scene represents the white man’s
conquest to take control over America and
the destruction it caused to Native American
communities -- the blatant disregard for Indian
culture on their journey to commit mass genoci--
-- nah I’m just kidding this is just a fun
scene where they break stuff.
Also -- Kemo Sabe, the name of the place they
stopped off in is a phrase used by Tonto in
the classic Western television series The
Lone Ranger, which oddly enough has come up
in two consecutive Things You Missed episodes.
Hi ho Silver, ROLL IT.
“Why you….
You Kemosabe.”
“Kemo… sabe?
That sounds familiar.”
“That’s right Kemosabe.
You trusty scout.”
“Trusty, scout?”
So naming this location Kemo Sabe fits in
perfectly with the themes of Zombieland.
At the beginning they are each rogue scouts,
but in order to thrive, each of them has to
learn to trust each other.
Kemo Sabe.
Trusty scouts.
Their next destination is Hollywood, where
they stay at Bill Murray’s house, and one
night they discuss what the best parts of
Zombieland are.
"No no no. Best thing about Z-land:
No facebook status updates.
You know, "Rob Curtis is gearing up for Friday."
Who cares?”
The actor that plays Columbus is named Jesse
Eisenberg, and less than one year later he
would play Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg
in the David Fincher movie, The Social Network.
The Social Network was casted in summer of
2009, a bit after Zombieland was shot in February
2009 -- HOWEVER -- both were produced by Columbia
Pictures and distributed by Sony, so it’s
possible that when Zombieland was created,
they had they inside scoop that Eisenberg
was probably going to play Zuckerberg, and
put in that joke.
Because it isn’t all that funny without
the context.
But like the discussion about the best parts
of Zombieland, it’s the character relationship
scenes that make this movie stand out above
many other zombie flicks, like the romantic
scene between Columbus and Wichita.
They discuss what each of them was doing in
1997.
What was I doing in 1997?
I guess I would have been in pre-K. Wichita
says she saw her first R-Rated movie in ‘97.
Ironically, my first R-rated movie came out
in 1997 as well.
I didn’t see it in 1997... obviously...
but we do kind of have that in common.
When Wichita tells about her first kiss, Columbus
asks her, “you guys use tongue?”
This may be because he’s still a little
bit traumatized about what happened last time
he had a crush on a girl.
Yeah.
So the girls leave Bill Murray’s house the
next morning, and by the way I find it a little
hard to believe that Bill doesn't have any
Cubs memorabilia.
I mean, they had just come off of two division titles
at the time.
Anyway, the girls go to the theme park and
turn on the power, and I love how the rides
are just immediately going, like as soon as
the power goes on all the rides just start
running like something out of a theme park
creepypasta.
At the end of the movie Tallahassee does finally
get his Twinkie, however, there are four
Twinkies that he overlooked over the course
of the adventure.
The first was when they come across the crashed
Hostess truck, but it’s filled with Snowballs.
"Snowballs? Snowballs?
Where's the dang Twinkies?!"
But, if Tallahassee had looked just a little
bit further, he would have found a bunch of
Twinkies stashed behind the other door of
the truck.
Then, in the grocery store, he walks right
past the Twinkies while he’s taking out
this zombie.
"You got a purdy mouth."
Just kidding. If any of you have seen this image it's actually Photoshopped. It's not real.
And finally, in the snack shack, moments after
Columbus blows a bullet shell through the
last remaining box of Twinkies, Tallahassee
turns on the lights to the storage pantry,
not sure how he knew where the lightswitch
was, but he somehow overlooks the Twinkies
sitting on the shelf.
But there’s one more long yellow treat filled
with a sweet filling; and it comes just after
Tallahassee loses his car to Wichita and Little
Rock.
The Hummer.
“Thank God for rednecks!”
The Hummer truly is Tallahassee's Twinkie
that he never knew he wanted.
The yellow metal covering the outside offers
him the protection he needed to survive in
Zombieland, and the sweet filling is the guns
they find in the back seat, which give them
a much needed means of fighting back against
the zombies.
The happiest we see Tallahassee, other than
when he meets Bill Murray, is when he gets
his two Twinkies.
“Something about a Twinkie reminded him
of a time not so long ago, when things were
simple and not so ****ing psychotic.
It was like if he got a taste of that comforting
childhood treat, the world would become innocent
again and everything would return to normal.”
And so it does, when these four survivors
put away their trust issues to become sort
of like a family.
But do they stay that way?
We’ll find out in Zombieland 2, and you’ll
find out some of the Things You Missed in
next week’s episode, so make sure you subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.